des loges avec un accès direct à la
scène c'est l'une des principales
nouveautés du théâtre de buc la salle
utilisée depuis une quarantaine d'années
s'est refait une beauté
c'est attaquer vraiment aux problèmes de
base c'est-à-dire refaire toutes les
parties et perches
tout ce qui est électrique avoir deux du
matériel neuf et récents donc voilà et
puis bien sûr essayer de l'amortir en
évitant tout ce qui est de location
puisqu'avant au loup et pas mal de
matériel et l'idée c'était de mobiliser
tout le potentiel de la ville pour
partir dans cette aventure culturelle et
surtout donner une identité culturelle à
la ville de buc donc ça a commencé tout
petit on a mobilisé les artistes les
partenaires les sponsors la ville il ya
mis beaucoup un million d'euros de
travaux ont été engagés sur
l'intersaison la salle qui reçoit des
artistes depuis 2018 a vu sa scène à
baisser et agrandi plus de 300
spectateurs peuvent assister aux 35
dates qui font vivre la saison du coin
des dates bien régulière notamment des
événements qui sont récurrents
aujourd'hui à buc l'idée étant d'être
vraiment éclectique de répondre à tout
le monde nous aimons accueillir les
familles nous aimons et cueillir le
jeune public nous aimons accueillir les
jeunes
donc on essaie vraiment de répondre à
tous les goûts le prochain rendez-vous
sera musical archie lee hooker fera
vivre la huitième édition de buchan
blues
[Musique]
solon